Salut! En ce jour des astuces, nous allons
parler de créativité
7 astuces pour booster, stimuler votre créativité
quand vous avez un projet à faire,
que ce soit artistique, personnel ou
professionnel.
Il faut déjà distinguer la créativité de l'imagination.
C'est pas parce qu'on doit créer quelque chose, qu'on doit avoir nécessairement un
maximum d'imagination.
L'imagination, c'est ce qui n'existe pas, et la création, c'est ce qui existe.
donc on peut tous
créer quelque chose! Et ça, c'est plutot une bonne nouvelle
Première astuce, il faut passer la peur de l'échec.
Ne vous jugez pas de ce que
vous produisez comme création.
Il sera toujours temps de l'améliorer, soyez
dans un état d'esprit positif,
ne jugez pas votre propre travail
laissez le venir comme il vient, brut
il y a d'abord la création d'une première matière, et c'est cette matière là qu'on va retravailler après.
si on cherche atteint la perfection dès
le départ, on se juge et en fait on se bride dans la créativité.
Deuxième
astuces: notez vos idées!
ça parait évident mais ça l'est pas forcément.
Dès que vous avez une idée quelconque,
qui vienne sur ce que vous travaillez
en ce moment, ou pas, notez la,
sur votre téléphone portable, dans un carnet, ou vous voulez,
mais ne la laissez pas filer.
Vous pensez que vous vous en souviendrez le jour où vous en aurez besoin,
C'est complètement faux
vous l'oublierez d'ici là.  Notez tout ce qui
vous paraît utile et encore plus ce qui vous parait inutile.
Ce qui est inutile
aujourd'hui sera peut-être utile demain
Troisième astuce: quand vous êtes en
pleine phase de création sur un sujet défini,
que c'est une vraie volonté
d'aller dans ce sens là,
si vous bloquez ou si vous voulez vous stimulez
différemment
changez de lieu de travail
ça fonctionne très très bien d'aller
dans un autre endroit,
ne serait-ce que dans un café avec son ordinateur,
chez quelqu'un d'autre, en vacances, ailleurs
quelque chose qui fonctionne bien sur
moi par exemple, c'est d'aller dans un espace de co-working
je fais la même chose qu'ici au bureau, chez moi,
mais je suis stimulé différemment.
Quatrième astuce, évitez de vous embourber dans une mauvaise direction.
c'est-à-dire, autant il ne faut pas se juger,
autant, si vous prenez un axe, une direction et que rien ne vient au bout d'un jour,  deux jours
que vous voyez qu'il y avait une bonne idée de base,
mais qu'elle est pas vraiment exploitable, en fait, y'a rien qui se lie, ça, ça arrive
on a une bonne idée, un truc, mais en même temps cette bonne idée c'est à la fois le frein de tout le reste.
Dans ces cas-là, vous pouvez aussi
essayer de passer à autre chose.
Seth Godin disait par rapport à la créativité : échouer
échouer rapidement et échouer souvent. C'est tout à fait l'idée,
ne pas hésiter aussi de passer une idée à une autre et de ne pas s'enliser
dans un espèce de bourbier dans lequel
on n'arrive pas à s'en sortir
5e astuce qui fonctionne très bien
aussi, dézoomer et rester un maximum dans le flou
rester dans le lointain si
vous devez travailler sur un sujet spécifique,
ne pensez pas à ce sujet
spécifique, pensez à une espèce de
globalité pour écrire des choses ou
réfléchir à des choses qui n'ont pas
un gros lien direct avec le focus initial
le fait de dézoomer ça
va permettre d'amener des idées qui
peut être n'ont pas un vrai sens au
départ
sur ce que vous essayez de créer mais
qui vont apporter quelque chose et qui
vont surtout vous apporter une autre mécanique
mentale un bon exercice pour ça c'est
le brainstorming qu'il se fasse tout seul ou à plusieurs moi quand je dois faire un
brainstorming tout seul j'utilise les mindmaps, les cartes mentales dont
on a parlé plein de fois sur cette chaîne, et à plusieurs le brainstorming
ça fonctionne merveilleusement
bien
si vous voulez je vous ferai un jour un Master Class sur le brainstorming
dites le moi dans les commentaires
si ça vous tente. Sixième astuce,
sur laquelle je vais pas m'attarder parce que j'ai fait une vidéo là-dessus c'est de
sortir de sa zone de confort ça va vous nourrir en créativité en rencontrant
des nouvelles personnes, en allant voir un spectacle, en faisant une
activité dont vous n'avez pas
l'habitude
ces expériences-là vont nourrir votre
créativité
et vont vous apporter des points de vue différents, quel que soit le sujet
sur lequel vous travaillez en ce moment. Hier, par exemple j'ai fait une vidéo avec Shirley
de la chaîne "je suis modeste" c'est pas du tout ma zone de confort les chaînes beauty
mais c'était intéressant et ça m'a
donné plein d'idées pour la suite
et enfin la septième et dernière
astuce qui est peut-être une des plus
essentielles avec le brainstorming et le fait de noter ses idées enfin je suis
en train de vous dire qu'elles sont toutes aussi importantes mais je crois que c'est ça
de temps en temps abordez votre
création votre problématique de
création d'une manière générale
comme si ce n'était pas la votre comme
si c'était pas pour vous. Une fois qu'on
se désimplique du projet on a un meilleur
regard dessus, c'est pour ça qu'on est
toujours très bon à donner des
conseils aux autres, avoir un point de
vue objectif sur les autres, à leur donner
souvent des très très bons conseils
quelque soit même l'action qu'ils sont
entrain de faire on a toujours un point de vue très pertinent c'est assez étonnant
qu'on n'arrive pas à le retrouver pour
nous et la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'on
peut le retrouver il faut plus imaginer
le lien qui relie le projet à vous et
regarder ça comme si c'était un pote à vous qui vous le présentait. Y'a une bonne technique aussi
c'est de donner tout projet à un pote un, à un ami ou quelqu'un de la famille
qui l'étudie, qui le comprenne, laisser
passer deux trois jours et après il
vient vous le vendre, il vient vous l'exposer
et vous le regardez et vous l'écoutez
comme si il parlait de sa création à lui
je prends le mot "création" au sens large ça peut être un projet de vie, ça peut être un
projet artistique ça peut être écrire un
bouquin, faire une musique, monter une
société, créer un nouveau produit par
le mot "création" j'entends le mot
développer une idée quelqu'elle
soit. Voilà pour ces 7 astuces du mercredi
puisque le mercredi c'est le jour des
astuces où je vous donne des astuces j'espère
que cette vidéo vous a plu merci
de l'avoir regarder. Si
vous avez aimé n'hésitez pas à me le
faire savoir en laissant une petite
création personnelle de votre part,
nous allons dire un petit pouce en l'air
par exemple. Vous pouvez également
commenter je lis
tous les commentaires, j'en rate aucun. Histoire de vous teaser un petit peu
demain on parlera de l'expérience
de Milton, samedi y'aura un masterclass sur la
lecture rapide puisque vous l'avez
demandé, vendredi je mentalise Terrene Trash
et dimanche prochain je vous
explique un tour pour bluffer
d'autres personnes mais comme on en a parlé déjà depuis quelques semaines
je vous ferai la démo d'abord de ce
tour sur quelqu'un avant de vous l'expliquer
comme ça vous aurez la démonstration en plus. Allez n'oubliez pas de vous
abonner avant de partir puisque le
Mental Vlog c'est une vidéo par jour
pendant un an, rendez-vous demain à 17 heures, ciao!